après le meurtre de bernard laroche
l'homme qu'on avait suspecté d'être
l'assassin du petit grégory et qui hier
a été tué d'un coup de fusil par le père
de l'enfant christine villemin la mère a
été placée aujourd'hui à garde en garde
à vue et la police interroge le juge
lambert chargé de l'instruction est
rentré de vacances précipitamment et
puis nouveau rebondissement
on est maintenant en cause un capitaine
de la gendarmerie mario laroche
l'accusent d'avoir provoqué le meurtre
de son mari
les gendarmes eux étaient décisives l'a
fait pour ça que le capitaine et cela
n'a pas été poussé jean marie plusieurs
fois au laos il lui dit c'était lui tu
es la route c'était la rouge qui
formaient comment vous expliquer le
geste de jean marie villemin qui tue de
sang-froid votre mari il a été poussé
joue 10 pouces et cela et puis sa fin la
question se pose à notre avis du rôle de
christine villemin dans la préparation
d'assassinât de bernard laroche
elle n'a pas hésité à mettre en route en
cause personnellement le capitaine cesma
qui selon elle aurait joué le rôle de
directeur de conscience de jean marie
villemin dans ses projets criminels